eight years of the National Football
League Panthers Vikings Chiefs Giants
and a little bit of a cup of coffee with
the lines before he tapped out and he's
uh making a name for himself in the
media business Jeff Schwartz get to see
you sir
so while can you lift up that microphone
that just kind of fell down there you go
there we go yeah we had we had Bob on on
the other day that's as big as we've
ever had to put the microphone up
somewhere so maybe it could be Stan the
stand up hasn't recovered I don't think
he's a giant human he is a genuine yeah
thank you kind of big yourself Jeff yeah
but he's like another oh that's true
that is true yes that is absolutely true
so let's let's get to one of the hot
stories in the league right now with
what happened with the New York Jets
last week I wonder what your thoughts
are on all of that yeah well I feel like
they were upset the Knicks got the
headline from the lottery just had to do
something in New York to get the
attention back so they fired their GM
the problem with the Jets is what
happens with a lot of teams you have a
disconnect between your front office and
your head coach right they don't work
together and I understand it has worked
at times I played for the Giants a lot
of times the decisions about player
personnel were done above Tom Coughlin's
head and obviously Tom Coughlin made it
work I'm in other places like you
mentioned Detroit where they kind of
draft and pick up guys together it's
like that's the best way to go is you
you bring in players that your coaching
staff can work with and that they want
obviously right so Adam GaSe doesn't
want
Le'Veon Bell he's gonna use them
obviously but you don't want your head
coach to kind of resent their paying a
player this much money they're gonna try
to find a way to eventually get rid of
this guy as soon as possible because the
coach doesn't like him so they need to
get in connection with what the coach
wants with the front office once this
happens way too often the NFL they get
players the coaches don't want the dome
for the system here for me I didn't even
fit what the Giants wanted to do on
offense
I fit nothing with Ben McAdoo you wanted
to do but they want in anyways I'm glad
I went there I was happy to be a giant
but I think nothing the Giants want to
do on offense they saw me anyways I
disconnected times between what the
front office wants and what the coaching
staff wants and the Jets are great
example why wouldn't Adam GaSe want levy
on bill
I mean not at that price I think the
value and price of what you pay a player
comes in to what a coach wants to do
with the player obvious
lady I'm Belle and I love running backs
I put agent Peterson Jamal Charles
double trouble in Carolina they're
awesome they made my career great but
the value in paying them is just not
there in the NFL and the word is is that
it was in ownership mandated signing you
damn straight it's an ownership mandate
90 million dollars under the app okay so
the money needs to be spent to a certain
floor any way that the in terms of this
franchise right this franchise got the
quarterback right in terms of getting it
getting in there and getting him up to
speed and Donald shows some excellent
ability and he's a tremendous person and
a great face front
yes face to have out there you got that
one straightened out
you got Jamal Adams who is in the back
end of that defense and he is as my
buddy prime calls a dog okay he is a dog
and a culture changing individual on the
back end there and what do you need in
New York City if you're the Jets and you
have you that guy levy on bail
go get him and if you're a coach who
doesn't want that money to be spent on
the on the running back and the owners
saying this is what I want then you
should know which organization you
signed up with this is the Jets these
things happen with the Jets if you
didn't want to do that if you didn't
want to be in a situation where this
stuff gets overruled
then just know where you've signed to
you know I understand wine the splash
the Jets franchise should be Sam Donald
should be forward-facing which I think
he will end up being obviously Le'Veon
Bell as a splash guy you don't have to
spend all your money the Colts have a
ton of money they didn't spend a lot in
Frasier see the value of pain Le'Veon
Bell especially as much as they did when
it seemed to be no other bidders who
else was bidding for Le'Veon Bell that's
part of this too is that gates look and
say who else was gonna pay maybe on bail
he said look and and again I like case I
think that he deserves the shot he's
just been hiring this sort of crazy to
be said right and and I saw what Kenyan
Drake did in his offense I mean it was
his offense is gonna be very good I know
Bell in his offense with Darnell doing
what he's doing Jeff Schwartz and you've
got those likely the receivers that they
have that are becoming to get that kid
in new McCann just wondering run over
you and Robbie Anderson can take the top
of the defense off and curse from the
Seahawks a couple years ago when they're
putting some people together here that
they have an opportunity if they don't
piss levy on fellows up for his first
OTA it's crazy
why he's not there either well because
take a look at Rueben foster in Foster's
hard off right now I know it's
unfortunate I know you can't predict it
but until you're you high know
physically beat look and here's I will
say this to Jeff you know if I'm part of
a new organization for me professionally
yeah and they pay me a ton of money and
they say and they say they say hey we're
having an event that's kind of character
building for the entire staff we want
you there even though you don't have to
we want you there I would be there
correct but me showing up me showing up
doesn't mean that my entire livelihood
to do the job that I've been hired to
could be cut out from under me without
me understanding it fair knowing it
injuries don't happen as much as we
think they do as far as his career
endings he's a nice there when they do
happen they make major news like Rueben
foster hopefully he's okay
they make major news they don't happen
as much as we think they do but in this
offense cases offense it's a complicated
office I play in a version of this
offense in Detroit it's a very wordy
it's multiple things happening multiple
snap counts multiple formations a lot
happens in line of scrimmage bail needs
to be there to learn this stuff
training camp is not as intense as used
to be it's hard to cram all the sin he
doesn't have to be in the field just be
there talk to Sam Donald figure out what
you do the linemen like just being the
facility I'm not that upset about it's
voluntary we negotiated that I'm fine
with it being the way it is but just
kind of beat it they paid all this money
just show up and kind of team build with
with Sam Donald you have to be like do
you be close with him you're at least
there for two years
hmm did you hear up Jeff Schwartz here
around other Rich Eisen show Pat Shermer
said he lies looking great
I see videos he's looking good I mean
yeah it's offseason most guys look good
oh man I just I don't even know where to
begin with that I think they're gonna
keep you as long as he can stand out
right I just can't see them cutting Eli
I think it comes from an ownership
decision at the very top we talked about
that with the Jets they love you I get
it he won two Super Bowls for them I
like playing with Eli is a great guy
he's a great worker he's great front
facing guy for the Giants organization
yes I think we get him and said they're
gonna wait three years I think they mean
it I think until I gets hurt and he's
done I doesn't get hurt he never missed
his games if he is just okay this year
and the Giants are 88 let's say they
improve right there close to the
playoffs not quite there yet they
improve they have pieces they have good
parts on offense defense guy be kid
about our pass rush and they go 88
they're not gonna play Daniel Jones next
year sure they are they have to realize
got one year left on his contract
yeah so in order for the three-year plan
to be done they have to resize him if
they residing they need to do it before
he plays a snap or if I'm alive this we
do it before he plays snap this year
correct because that way if they go you
know four and six to start the season or
they finish up eight and eight you do
have to basically say we're done here
let's see what Daniel Jones can do and
throw them in the deep end in the fool
don't you think I mean they tried to go
seventh up well Gino Smith said it was
no problem was they went with Gino not
Davis Webb what you wanted no it was not
they got with Davis Webb it wouldn't
have been such an uproar they were with
a guy that was not the future it was
never the future and they said Davis
Webb you're in it was never the future
either but if they were to put him in
I'm telling you they're the Giants fans
don't seem as excited for Daniel Jones I
drafted a guy that fans aren't really
excited to see it buys them more time
with Eli Manning I know that Davis what
that you hit on it harshly that when
they went to Davis where they'd went to
Geno Smith instead of Davis Webb they
went with a guy that wasn't the future
direct but they also want with a guy who
the rest of New York City had a front
row seat to know he was not the few
threats so it was you are not even
reading the room we weren't reading your
own room you weren't read entire room of
the New York City metropolitan area and
that guy over there Brockman thinks that
that Mac of do is doing that the
organization of favor the
they should have just not gonna do is
right the whole time he was right the
whole time
I totally agree organizations set
themselves back by not doing the tough
thing Bilbao check has always done that
right he's always done the tough thing
even the colts peyton manning one year
hurt getting older all right we'll get
andrew luck move on
the giants just don't seem at least
outwardly to want to do that it's
holding them back they should a draft at
donal last year never had this problem
you drafted a running back i said a
franchise quarterback makes no sense to
me
Jeff Schwartz here on the Rich Eisen
show and right now is we're sitting here
the Monday before Memorial Day I don't
see a team that's gonna beat the
Patriots this year I'm sorry I on the
only the only way that the Patriots
could be beaten just knowing what
they've got coming back yeah I know that
Gronk's not there everyone's gonna take
that cheese Gronk snot there yeah
everyone's gonna be everyone's gonna
keep eating that cheese september in
first parts of october when they have
trouble potentially on us yes everyone's
gonna keep taking that cheese and to me
I'm not taking it because I know that
Belichick is gonna have this team in a
certain spot by a certain week the only
thing that can hold them back is if
suddenly Brady's physical attributes
fall apart just because that's what
happens to people in this war even
though you know your EES instagramming
on pictures of him looking he looked fit
dynamite okay and he is working out in
May that's the only way that I see tell
me I'm I'm wrong and I don't say that
meaning that I have to be right but I
I'm open for suggestions here the one
team that can do it is the Chiefs we saw
them lose at home last year the
difference in 2019 in my opinion the
Patriots will have home-field advantage
throughout the playoffs their schedule
sets up perfectly twelve and four
thirteen and three and to your point I
can't see anyone going into New England
and winning that game if it was back in
Kansas City
learning after last I could see that
she's doing it my brother obviously
plays for the Chiefs I root for the
Chiefs but they're gonna take a little
step back if Tyree kills not there
obviously you have to replace it and
they did last year cream hunt everything
went really well for the Chiefs last
year defense transitioning with spaags
probably won't be as kind of there
throughout the year getting as they
improve I think to your point New
England look they drafted in Akhil Harry
to be that big possession wide receiver
right
wina vich I like that pic as well nice
Hall corner and Joanne Williams
who is 6-3 can play press can do
whatever they want their defense
interchangeable parts and again their
schedule sets up great they have their
their toughest games I believe Chiefs at
home right theaters at home Cowboys at
home everything at home they're gonna be
13 and three twelve and four have home
field throughout and the only team the
Chiefs on the only team I think that can
go to can't go to New England in late
January with Pamela Holmes and even keep
compete in that game well we'll see what
the Colts morph into if they can maybe
take even another quantum leap forward
the quantum leap that they took less you
nobody saw coming if they've got another
one in them I'm I'm willing to see that
I'm willing to see what the Chargers can
do there's always a surprise team I
don't know which one it is the Steelers
- Bell I like to stand and Brown they're
gonna be able to use the nobody believes
in his car that they never are able to
use and we got Joe Manganiello coming up
in studio and our number three to
discuss that and Thrones you know what
about the Rams what about what we saw
from the Rams that they that they
couldn't score on the Patriots but
they've given another chance a mulligan
yeah with another round of mcveigh
injecting his genius into the equation
what do you think here I appreciated
McVeigh admitting he over prepared for
that game but it was totally obvious
they they just they looked like they had
they just were too confused on what's
happening
I like the Cowboys in the NFC I told you
that Brockman I wrote about this other
day I tell them that Chris you did every
year an NFC there's a different team
kind of out of nowhere the the the
Falcons the Eagles the Rams last year we
work on a known quantity every year
there seems to be the Panthers in 15 out
of nowhere team comes up in the Cowboys
last year obviously were in the playoffs
we have not had a repeat winner in the
NFC since 2004 so an FCE so we have to
break that trend obviously I think to
get back to where they want to go but
you added Randle called great second way
for energy signing Amari Cooper yeah
when Travis Frederick being back at
center is a huge plus for them how so
last year they had a problem the first
eight weeks of the year and really when
they're off until on coaches fire to
help
they just were not idea who they were
gonna meet so many mental mistakes of
not just knowing who they were working
to it was mind blowing and that can make
you cooler young quarterback look
totally confused and also just blows up
your run game everything right Frederick
is back there healthy in the offensive
line now and DeMarcus Lawrence Crawford
they have a great linebackers there but
good back in their secondary the Giants
aren't that strong the Eagles gonna be
good the Redskins aren't that strong in
my opinion I think the Cowboys i-if dak
can take the next step which will see
what the weapons he has I didn't they're
gonna be suitable do you put a 3 in
front of an eight-figure annual salary
for Dec Prescott Jeff Schwartz oh man
cuz that's what that's right that that's
what your market I know I know
this is tough I thought or not I think
dat is not cohort elite but the Cowboys
are stuck I mean you gonna have to pay
him and just hope you surround him with
parts that help him is he does he not
elite though because because he hasn't
dominated like Patrick mahomes did he -
you know what I'm saying are we are
reviewing him through the prism of well
other people other people's quarterbacks
have been doing it this I mean we've
seen when his little when his weapons
have been limited he has not been able
to raise his play above those weapons
where other people have been able to do
that in this position that's why this
year with Cobb there and Cooper and I'm
hoping this offense with Kelly more
they're more aggressive I want to see
that I want to deal offense it seems
like what 30 years younger than me it's
wild
I hope they're more aggressive I want to
see a different offense in Dallas before
I can completely make my judgment on
that Prescott telling you I told brought
them like this division and you wrote
about this Jeff Schwartz and SB cowboy I
don't know what their what their number
is in Vegas but I liked them a lot by
the way you got a gambling
brother-in-arms over there I have a look
at the future for that I mean did you
who did you have like individual points
in a game that you were complaining
about he had 22 points entering the
fourth quarter had him at 23 and a half
he Dominguez single bucket for six in
the fourth quarter we wondered happen
now we know he's screwed to end then
last night over 23 and half a guinea and
it were 23 missed five foul shots this
is possible only I don't
like Jeff I'm not allowed to but I would
suggest you just get off the CJ McCollum
bandwagon tonight he's do i I don't
still I'm gonna have that tonight I've
been pretty hard on him MBA it's been AI
was a three no yesterday so it was
awesome curry over I'd ride Raptors
first quarter first half and Bucs third
quarter what do you got tonight for all
of our I have not decided on tonight I
feel like it's an in-game wagering night
I don't like anything right now under I
loved live betting maybe the under is
just played before the game huh yeah why
do you think that the Warriors go under
a lot without Kevin Durant okay and the
Blazers in with Daniel's injury just
haven't been scoring as much I think
it'll be tight tonight the question is
do they come out in the first quarter
and go really hard I'm kind of tempted
to say that warriors come out fast in
this game to just put an end to the
series so my gosh
we'll see we have we have we have eight
hours to decide what not what do you
think of your Lakers down the street Oh
does it dumpster fire I don't think it's
gonna be good till Cheney sells the team
she's not selling the team she no she
shouldn't sell the team five million
dollars they can go ahead because of
higher and that's why probably any
general manager they wanted to come in
to fix this and you just don't want to
do it she wants to stay in house and
with the Rama says help her what are the
ramiz's know about about basketball the
basketball side of this thing like
actually like player development and
that type of stuff and drafting also
look LeBron was supposed to bring in
another player and that has not happened
yet well let's see July ones big July a
July one is a huge yes huge week if they
fail glory lift it's for the Warriors
the Knicks the Lakers the nets the
Celtics hella can't just off the top my
head the pelicans Sixers
just off the top of my head I just named
those team operators Raptors to the
Clippers the Clippers might get or have
a better team than the Lakers because P
players don't want to play for the
Lakers I'm never gonna have it if the
Clippers have two aces in the hole three
they've got the owner the coach and
Jerry West yep that can walk in the room
the owner could basically say I am nuts
but I am rich and I love much that I
love
and this is all I care about okay and
Doc Rivers can say look what I did last
year
who called Doc Rivers a coach of the
Year candidate in December gave you
credit right and he's one of the three
finalists I gave you credit okay and
Jerry whisk can basically say just look
by the way you see the logo right there
that's me yeah that's me and you know
what I did with the Lakers do you see
what I did with the gritted my I got
handed a bunch of lemons from the
lemonade of a top overall picking a
draft lottery fourth overall I chose
Mike Conley guess what I did with the
Warriors you see that you see that up
there who is the one who whispered to
Durant you should come here
Jerry what's the greed so I'm saying
okay so SP nation has helped everyone
that's it where's Jeff Schwartz I have a
website that's gonna be ready soon
Schwartz NFL calm it's getting there
that's gonna be my go to says saying my
Twitter handle just okay go there it's
getting up we should should be soon we
can have te o FS how you spell exactly
okay Jeff Schwartz here thanks for
letting me know you're in town I'll have
you on anytime that's Jeff Schwartz here
on the Rich Eisen show for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app